demming wie viele leute von sich jetzt
sorgen zu machen ob wir auf einen neuen
weltkrieg zu steuern
das glaube ich nicht der amerikanische
präsident hat zwar martialische sprüche
wieder mal losgelassen aber ich glaube
letzten endes sind beide seiten also die
vereinigten staaten russland daran
interessiert die sache nicht außer rand
und band geraten zu lassen
jedenfalls war das eine aus meiner sicht
frivole unbeherrschtheit des präsidenten
das kennt man ja mittlerweile von ihm
gasse einfach irgend so etwas
unbeherrscht das vom stapel lässt das
wird dann von seinem von seinem stab von
ministern wird das versucht wieder
einzufangen
das haben wir eine handelspolitik so das
hatten wir gegenüber nordkorea schon
erlebt man fragt sich wirklich ob dieser
mann etwas sogar statt gezielt einsetzt
diese unberechenbarkeit oder ob das eine
art ist persönlich glaube das ist sein
seine art sein stil und morgen sagt er
vielleicht ganz was anderes morgen later
vielleicht hat putin ins weiße haus ein
und dann kommen sie zu einem deal und
dann wird alles wieder gut so zusagen
für einen amerikanischen präsidenten der
jahrzehntelang der führer des westens
war der
moralisch auch eine gewisse und
politisch eine gewisse respekt abily tät
ausstrahlte das ist eine zu
amerikanischen präsidenten nicht würdig
aber auch unabhängig von einem weltkrieg
das bringt ja allein dramatisch dass man
warte ich weiß was wir davon halten soll
die lage im nahen osten ist kompliziert
ist verfahren sie ist schlimm die
bevölkerung leidet dramatisch und wenn
es tatsächlich stimmen sollte dass
wieder an giftgasangriff verübt worden
ist durch das regime des präsidenten
assad und mutmaßlich dann unter wissen
vielleicht sogar komplizenschaft
russland dann wäre das eine furchtbare
sache ob russland tatsächlich glücklich
ist ich habe zwar gesagt komplizenschaft
jedenfalls de facto das giftgas
eingesetzt wird
egal was wie das jetzt geleugnet wird
als provokation dargestellt wird davon
mal abgesehen
das glaube ich nicht dass das eigentlich
richtig gut finden können denn das führt
doch nur zu einer weiteren verhärtung
dieser all in schwierigen lage zwischen
russland und westlichen ländern
[Musik]